[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Good afternoon, sir.
>> What's going on, buddy?
How's the battle going?
>> Still fighting.
>> Yeah, any pain relief or still?
>> Things have gotten better in the last 24 hours.
>> That's good.
>> Which is a nice relief cuz I'm so tired of being in pain all the time.
>> Yeah.
>> So I was able to get to the grocery store today and walk around and
not feel like I needed to lie down.
[LAUGH]
>> Look at you doing adult things.
>> I know.
[LAUGH]
>> So yeah, hopefully this is the beginning of the end.
>> Good, and hopefully it is.
All right, let me bring up what we're working on so
we can talk a little bit about that and the next steps I'd like to go.
So let me just get it set up on the screen here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
More importantly, I wanna get in the right project here.
And I'm recording this call, so we're good.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I have it open if you want me to share my screen.
>> Yep, nope, I've got it.
I just wanna make sure I get the most, okay, good, yep, okay.
So I'm just gonna move my.
Chat to my bigger monitor.
You were on the smaller one, nice shirt, man, a lot of meetings today.
>> I had a podcast today.
>> Nice.
>> Wear my era shirt.
>> Perfect, okay.
Are we looking at the grid here, correct?
>> I don't see it.
Well, here it comes.
>> I am now looking at your chat GPT window.
>> Wrong one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let me just share the entire window.
>> It's starting to come into focus, there it is.
>> Perfect, okay, good.
So, two things I wanna look at.
Number one, aesthetics, ease of use, looking at the data, functionality.
And then we'll get into things that we can do to obviously improve it and
make sure it's there with what you're looking for.
So I'm thinking ideally Jeff is, and again, I like to put your logos,
like a little more aesthetically, is you're gonna be able to,
we click on local practice, is one, you can manually be able to add a company.
So it doesn't always have to rely on the bulk uploads.
So if you come across a leader, something like that,
you'll be able to add in the opportunity, right from there, okay, right?
And or, as you think, I'm not sure if you've played around with it.
Where it comes in and you can actually score it yourself.
So you can almost relay some of the information that you've already got, and
then it'll still do the composite report for you, okay?
>> So where does that, cuz I did play around with it.
So a lot of the buttons that weren't able to be pushed because it's not ready to go
live, like the add opportunity button, activate review buttons.
None of those actually work, but I was clicked on the open research report.
That worked for you.
Maybe I was on the- >> Yeah, so
what you gotta do is you gotta try local practice mode, I think.
>> Okay, I see.
>> And then that should pop up here, okay?
>> Local practice mode.
Okay, now I can click on, can I click on the other buttons?
Does activate review do, okay.
>> I'll explain that in a minute.
>> Okay, all right, let's go back to you, that works.
>> Okay, so here's where we can put in a one-off that you get.
Company website, anything from Zune info, your preliminary score,
like, that's a pretty good fit, I think it's a four.
Here's maybe why, and then add it, and then it will add it to our workflow.
So we can trigger an add-on company, cuz what I realized is that all we were
doing was solely relying on the bulk uploads of the Zune info, and
not the one-off referrals that you would have gotten.
Had we put United Way and things like that in there, okay?
>> Okay.
>> So, second thing is you can obviously search so
we can find a company, cuz this is gonna start being a big list of things you've got.
Queued are the companies that are potentially ready to go, but haven't done.
Now, one of the things, Jeff, I wanna address is your token use, okay?
So we'll do a couple things in the next round.
Number one is I'm gonna re-shift the order of which we do things.
And the fact that we were taking all the companies, doing the research, and
then grading them.
And I think for the sake of our token usage is we identify the companies,
grade them on a certain criteria, before we go and
do all the deep research on it.
>> Okay.
>> All right, again, we can find out what that criteria is, but
we don't need to be going, and again, just my thoughts.
We don't need to be going into LinkedIn.
We don't need to be going deep into that to determine if it's a four or five or three.
>> How do we grade them without doing the research?
>> Well, that's what we're gonna find out.
I'm gonna test it, okay?
>> The other, I hear where you're going and from a process perspective,
it's like filter as much out with easy criteria as you can before you have
the engine really run.
>> Correct.
>> And I'm thinking the matching against Athena could also be a filter.
Because if something's already tagged, there's no sense in doing all the research
because we're not gonna go after that account.
>> Okay, good point.
I wasn't even thinking about that.
I was thinking, because what really sucked up in my understanding,
what sucked up a lot of the juice was the fact that we're going outside of chat GPT.
Meaning we're doing all this research on the web, on the browser, going to LinkedIn,
going to Zoom info, and going out of its lane of just staying within chat GPT.
Hardware, so to speak, okay, platform.
So that's what's sucking up a lot of our token use.
So how can we minimize that but still get the same benefit to the point where we're
only gonna do the deep dive research and maybe companies that are 3 and up, in ranking.
We can still have those 2s and 1s and 2s and say, all right, well, great.
Let me come back to them another time.
But right now, I'm gonna focus on the 3 and higher.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> The other issue that I was having with chat was,
it wouldn't complete the research without being prompted.
Like it would say, okay, yeah, let me finish that.
And then it would run, and run, and run, and it would only finish, and
then it would just stop, or it wouldn't complete the,
you know, it wouldn't complete the Athena check without me telling it,
did you check Athena?
And so for some reason, I kept having to prompt chat to continue, complete.
>> To take it to the next step.
So it would go from do step A, but then it wouldn't go to step B without you
prompting it and pushing it over, is that correct?
>> I'm not sure whether it was moving from one step to the next,
or if it was getting stuck in a particular step and not finishing that step.
>> Okay. >> Both.
I can show you some of the conversation.
I was starting to get mad at it.
>> Well, you know what, for context purposes, either screenshot that,
print that, or whatever.
So then share that with me so that I can see it, and we can train off of it.
>> Okay. >> Okay?
So, all right, go back.
So activate and review basically allows us to, once it's been done,
go in and say, okay, move to researching, move to queued or whole,
which means I don't want to deep dive into that research.
You follow me on that?
>> Walk me through that, because I think you're more familiar with the workflow
than I am.
>> Okay, when you hit activate review, that window opens, there's a lot in there.
So, am I supposed to fill out every one of these fields?
>> No, this is already, this should be done for you by the process.
>> Okay, so we're just looking at this because it hasn't run the process yet.
>> That's correct, yes, well this one actually has, okay, because we have a report ready to go.
All right, I think if I'm reading this correctly, it's already determined it's an excellent fit for you.
Here's the data, so basically this is giving you a quick summary of things and what's next.
>> So, why are the two big boxes at top and up?
There's nothing in there.
>> Oh, that is a great question.
>> I don't know if it's on the rank of the route, the contacts, none of that is filled in.
>> Let me make sure I'm reading this correctly here.
I wonder if this is because I coded this up only ranking three and up.
>> I think that is, yes, score three possible fit.
I think because it was the initial of the potential savings of it, I said only give
me companies that are three or higher and then we'll take it into the deeper dive.
>> Okay, so it hasn't, it's only through step one.
>> That's correct, I believe so because that's okay, yes, I understand that.
These are queued and these are approved, like done.
We're holding these that we've already either done because now I've got the open review done.
I think I did this, okay, we're holding this because this is a weak fit out of two.
>> So a whole, let's go to those top level things there, so all this, that's everything
in the research queue regardless of scoring.
>> Correct.
>> Queue means that it's queued up and needs some human intervention.
>> Yes, I asked it to build on a cheat sheet for me, so here we go.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> All right, and I apologize if I didn't send it over, I thought I did, but so this is,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let me just scan this cuz I briefly looked at it last week when I sent it to you.
All right, I'll dive deeper and there's a lot of info, but it's all good though, okay.
>> Okay. >> But it sounds like, is it queued?
>> Okay, so- >> I'm not sure what the,
maybe queued up for research, meaning those are the ones that qualified for a three or higher.
Research means it's in the process of being researched.
QA is asking me to QA the work, ready for approval.
I'm not sure the difference between these other QA review, ready for approval, approved.
>> Approved mean the research route is approved.
Every communication still needs separate human approval, okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, opportunity five fields, company name, we did that, coming to site, okay, yeah.
Well, you know what I can do is I can turn this into a whole little training video so
that both of us can understand exactly what is doing.
>> Okay. >> AI is still the smartest
person in the room right now, Jeff. >> All right, well, why don't you work on
that offline? >> Yes.
>> But if I generally understand from a
overall just flow perspective, the dashboard is better than what I was dealing with before.
So that's an improvement. And the cues, I like having cues as long as I understand what they mean.
They help me compartmentalize the work that needs to get done. And really, I need to understand
which ones I need to really be paying attention to, because I need to take human action on.
The research reports are good. It's an easy way for me to find the company's research report,
because that was one of the other issues that I was having was I was scrolling,
scrolling, scrolling, scrolling, trying to find whatever. So that link is helpful.
The activate review button, once I see how this operates, I'll be able to tell you more.
The one thing, does this, so when we were recently scoping this, the idea was to
be able to talk to chat and tell it, okay, that draft looks good. Go, execute.
Does this eliminate the ability to talk to chat? >> I don't want to answer that right now,
because we didn't get to that part in the build out. So if that is an option, I'm going to say
we can probably make it happen. So I wonder if when, at what point, Jeff, would you want to interact
with the data that way? Would it be, and on a side note, I'm going to, because right now this
pulls and opens up GitHub, so the report sits there, I want to make it so it's just a pop-up window,
like we just had with some of the other ones. So it's like something like this, and the report
will be right here. It's a little bit cleaner. So if there is a discussion button down here,
and that opens up and voice chat opens up, and you can interact with it? >> Ideally, it's
it's a matter of having to type as little as possible, right? The more that I can say, okay,
open a seed molding tool. Let's work on the activate review. And then it opens it up, and I can see the
thing that's whatever it's asking me to do to move to the next step. But I can just say, okay, move from
ending HubSpot, whatever, to cleared by Jeff, or something like that. Or just move to the next step.
I'm okay with the draft. Go ahead and send, or document HubSpot. The ability to be able to just
engage it like it's an assistant, as we talked about. If I had an assistant sitting next to me,
who would sit there going, all right, here's a seed tool. This is what I need from you. And I would
go, okay, yes, yes, go ahead and send it out. And then the assistant would go ahead and send it out,
kind of the same relationship I'm looking for here. >> Got it. >> Okay.
>> Yes. I think we're gonna have some fun trying that. >> That would be in a decision making
and approval mode, most of the work that's coming through here. >> Got it. So as I was playing
around with it, I noticed that, you know, I came back and we gave it. So I moved it from this,
from pending review to approved, cleared by Jeff, and approved. And that saved it, and that moved
it from queued to researching. So that, if I wonder if it now goes in and we'll do the research,
then we know, all right, this is now researching. And, you know, what is there? So you can see the
researching tool has been updated. So that might be just almost moving it through a pipeline.
But I wonder if a couple of these steps could be eliminated, to your point, and just you're now
just ready for approval. And that is reviewing the entire thing like here, like we just did.
Here's the draft. Here's the email that would go. Here's the report.
So this is the last step or two of your review and approval. And then I can simply go back,
back here and say, okay, yep. Push that to, where is it? Sorry, I got too many windows open here.
It was for the one to the left. Oh, yeah, there it is. Click a button approved,
push the hub spot and send. Something of that nature. Yeah, because that's the, in fact,
if you scroll up on this page, keep going all the way to those menu items. Oh, where'd it go?
Okay, go to recued.
And scroll, click activate review. Which one? Any of them? Any of them. Like in the,
if the thing that I need to, like this should be drawing my attention to the action that I need to
take. So I shouldn't have to figure out, okay, which field do I need to fill out here? What's
the thing that's gonna, it should really be a button that says move to next phase.
Or if it asks me and I can say, yeah, go ahead and move the next phase. But even if it's a button,
instead of a menu, me trying to figure out what does it mean to go from this stage to that stage?
If it's just telling me the next stage is cleared by Jeff and when I'm ready, I can just push the
button and it moves it to the next stage. Yeah, no, I'm tracking you. I think almost to this
and we eliminate all this stuff and just you're looking at this right here. So the conflicted,
is it cleared? Meaning that Athena, it's been approved in Athena and it's all set in hub spot.
So click here, start my research and then you should bypass all of this
and just ready for approval for sending it out.
Does that sound about right?
I think so, but I want to make sure I'm giving you the right direction. Let me repeat it back.
So it's in that stage. Let me click that. Now what this would say is conflict checks.
I don't know what that means.
So a conflict of not being a good lead for you is, is it already, did someone already
claim it in Athena? Okay, I think we can remove the hub spot and the Jeff check because
if it's in hub spot and we don't need it, but we're just, the only conflict would be in Athena,
right? That's actually essentially, okay, I'm going to put that thought to the side
for a moment because I want to stay here. So this should be
instead of a drop down menu, if there's a conflict, it should be prompting me with
what needs to be done about that conflict. Or yeah, like that, that's what I'm thinking about.
Like an alert button says, here's a conflict, do this.
Yeah. Right. Because right now I would look at that and go, all right, let's look at the menu and
I have to understand what the choices mean as opposed to it just telling me there's a conflict
with X. Do you want us to bypass the conflict or whatever it is? Is that the only one that it would
ask me to fill out? Like those other four menu boxes are the three menu boxes.
Do I need to be filling those out too? I'm going to say no, because again, we're trying to automate
as much work as possible for you. Now that I'm diving deeper into this, it's really just,
is there a conflict here or not? And if so, what do I got to do for it? Boom, move it to the next.
So if anything, it would be just conflict resolved, move to next phase, done. And it goes into the
deeper research or, you know, because right now it's like, oh, do we need to go to research in
Qt? I'd confirm just, you know, there's none of this. It's a, to me, it's a lot of data entry.
Yeah, exactly. Now that I'm walking it through with you. All right. You and I are on the same
page. The other idea I have that I put over here for a second is what is, it's one of the things
that it kept saying when I was in the version 1.0 was about HubSpot, as if it was doing some checks
in HubSpot. Do you know what it's doing in HubSpot? What it's looking for?
No, because I can't see into what you were doing because you're HubSpot. We connected that
and only use HubSpot. Post my chat and my, when we were online, we let it run for what you got.
I would say either, just for future reference, screenshot or print any one of those errors
or questions and send it to me as just, or save it, whatever. And that way I can learn from it and
build a workaround. Okay, I'll do that. What I was wondering, because it seemed like it was,
and I don't know if it actually was or is just saying these things. HubSpot,
I'm the only person in HubSpot, so they don't have to, the only reason it needs to look at HubSpot
is to do documentation and to refer to past conversations when it's drafting a new,
when it's drafting another communication. For example, like I'll show you what I do that way.
You're recording this, right? Yes. All right, let me share my screen so you can see,
can you see the screen now? Yes, I can. Okay, so when I'm following up with Mike Delacorta,
I'm not checking to see if this is somebody else's account or this is somebody else's contact.
It's all mine, right? So the only thing I'm looking for here is I actually will go in
and use HubSpot's AI Assistant and tell it.
And so I do that and it's going, it goes and it looks at all of the prior communication.
And there's a bunch of emails and stuff back to July.
And so it says, I'm finding Mike, checking recent activity, pulling email,
voice and template contacts once the recipient is resolved, blah, blah, blah.
I found the contacts, pulling in recent emails, calls, meetings, et cetera,
tied to the goodwill opportunity. I found goodwill, vancord email, verifying whether
any later CRM activity replies should be referenced.
My computer does not like me sharing my screen. It slows my cursor down so much.
I don't even have chat open.
It's usually not this slow. I think it's just because I'm sharing my screen.
Point being is it's going to pop out with an email that is already written.
I just have to review it and click send. And then I have to come over here and mark
the activity that just happened. Now the email, if it's an email, it'll automatically mark it.
But if it's a phone call, I have to go in and write a phone and put in here that a phone call
was made. It was an outbound call, left of voicemail. And so you can see here, it creates,
I couldn't save an Uber to the cameras right now, so here's the draft. I don't know why that is,
but usually it pops up with, here's your email. All you have to do is click send.
It may have something to do with how slow things are going. But for our purposes,
and the reason I wanted to show you that is the way the breeze assistant works,
and that's what I would assume the outreach engine is going to do. It's going to create,
it's going to look through the last few conversations, a thread of conversation in HubSpot,
and then it's going to draft an email based on that. Now most of these are going to be
new companies, so there won't be much to look at. But there might be something. And then it has to
come in here and document what was done. It was an email was sent, and this is the email
that was sent on this date at this time. So if the outreach engine is writing the email,
then it has to come in here, log an email, type the email in here, and even mark,
let's see if I send something to Mike. Even if it's three business days,
I'll just leave it three business days, just check this, and you log the email.
Does that make sense? Yes, this is all great flow that I need to understand.
Is there anything you see in here off the top of your head, and you may get off the call and think
about it some more, and then come back to me with a different answer. But is there anything you see
that you think the outreach engine just doesn't have the capability to do? Not yet until we test
it, to be honest with you. I don't know, I mean, the nice part about AI, you just keep asking it
to do it and see if it can. So whether that's going to be a direct able to do it through the
plugin, or it needs to take over your browser, that is well TBD. And we won't know that Jeff,
until we actually go and test it in this type of a format, or I'm sitting down next to you so it
doesn't lag, and say, "Okay, great, here's your task, take this and do it." But I will tell you
this, I've got to the point where I'm pointing to my secondary monitor with my second unit,
where I've got chat GPT, directing and drafting and creating draft emails in my Outlook,
with contact conversions. And if I say, "Send it to this group," it's sitting there waiting for me
to press through, review and press send. And in this case, that works just fine. Like I said,
most of these are going to be cold outreach, or they're going to be new outreach, if nothing else.
Yep. So there's not going to, like Breeze had to actually sift through all the different
messages that I've had since in the last three months with this guy. Most of these contacts,
there's not going to be anything to sift through, it's going to be a new thing. So it shouldn't take
too much processing. But it does need to come back into HubSpot and document the date, the time,
what the actual email said, and put a follow up task in. So here's something we can do, Jeff.
And if you need to create a dummy account for my coachproof enterprises in HubSpot,
and I can give you whatever information you need for that, is we can have it go from chat
to go create this account, a new account in HubSpot. All right, so now it's taking
the data from the report in theory and putting it in, just doing one test run. Then if that's
in there, then come back and say, okay, now go back in and send an email to Joe based on this,
make some shit up, and then see if it will then execute that task. Just directly from the plugin
in codex or work. Work is probably the better way to do it, because we can use less tokens. Okay.
Yeah. Because that, and again, I'm thinking about out loud here. So that will confirm
the workflow and the connectivity between chat, HubSpot, and task of a creating a whole new
company and entering data, task B drafting an email to said company and logging it as accordingly.
And we want it to draft from within HubSpot so that HubSpot can track opens and clicks.
Well, I think we want to send it from HubSpot. Right. That's what I mean.
Whether it's drafted in chat and copy and pasted. Yeah.
Yeah. Right. You're right. Yeah. It doesn't matter. As long as it's
officially sent through HubSpot, then HubSpot will track all the opens and clicks and stuff.
Okay. Making progress. We're getting there.
Yeah. No, I was pleasantly happy with the dashboard. And again, yes, it was a ton of info.
Now that I sit back and digest our conversation here, it's much easier to take things away than
try to figure out what's missing. So I think from that standpoint, it'd be easier.
Do me a favor because I'm looking over your shoulder at your screens. Either send me your
strategic operations logo or both, and I'll put them in here so it looks a little bit better
in aesthetically. And we can have some fun with naming it if you want.
We can call it Joe, Jeff's outreach engine. Oh, think about that one. Let me think about Joe.
But yeah, we can have some fun with it. But I certainly want to make sure it's aesthetically
pleasing because in essence, because now this is web-based, you should be able to open up on your
phone and your laptop and everything else as you work with things. So that's something to
think about down the road when we really get closer to a news case. So I'm going to take the
notes from our meeting. I'll work on this tonight. Obviously, I want to make sure progression because
this is all based on, yes, I want to complete the project, but I also want to make sure it's
working for you and you can get cranking on it. Do you want, you had mentioned something about
wanting to see it run on the Zoom stuff tomorrow. Do you think it'll be ready in time or do you want
to weigh in? Well, I'm going to take the notes from our meeting today and roll through. For the
sake of burning through credits, my one, once this is set up, the one thing that I challenge it on
is, okay, what's going to trigger? So is it now, can I make a scheduled task to now go and using
your Zoom info plugin to go pull those reports directly into the dashboard here so that it
executes it? Or do we still have to manually upload them ourselves? So right now, the only
trigger on this dashboard is us clicking the add, you know, an opportunity and manually putting one
in. So that's where my next iteration. So basically I started kind of like, here's the nuts of it.
Okay, now we go plug in the front end, plug in the back end and tweak it. Okay. Yeah, that sounds
right. Okay. All right. Well, if you get far enough along tonight and you want me to have it run
through those, but you know, when they come in tomorrow morning, or we can wait till Wednesday,
it doesn't really matter because they're going to be there regardless. Yeah. Well, why don't we do
this? If you could, why don't we test the HubSpot thing, as I just mentioned, okay? So again, create
a six-digit company, make it go to prevent whatever you want, AI growth plan. That way I can see
emails coming back and forth, and we can trigger that it got opened and things like that. And then
make, you know, whatever it is, it's a fit or whatever, make Big Bird as my chief executive
officer or whatever. And I'm pretty sure I have a two-user license here and I don't use the other
user, so I can assign that to you. I'll figure that out once we get off the call. So yeah, I'll
try to spin it around. And then again, I've got somewhat of a light week. Tomorrow, up till two,
I'm sort of open. And then Wednesday, up till I'm speaking in New Canaan around four. So until I get
a four-ish, and then Thursday, Friday, I'm good. So we can kind of continue working at your pace.
Cool. All right. All right, man. And you're going to be there Wednesday?
Wednesday, I should be able to be there Wednesday, assuming I don't have a, I don't go backwards and
how I feel. Like I even thought about dialing in the other day and I'm like, I'm so uncomfortable.
I'm not even going to be listening to anybody. Well, it turns out that I was mistaken in the
fact that Mark is the only Zoom guy. We only do it for Figgler. Because I went in there and
Laura's, I'm like, oh, we didn't have it set up. I'm like, oh, Jeff was going to Zoom in because
he's in pain at home. It's like, we don't do Zoom. Not bad. This week, didn't I see something that
is being held somewhere? Yes. Yes. It's at Sergio's place, Allen Sales. Okay. Okay. And why are we
going there? One, he offered to do it there. So it's kind of a change of pace. And then instead
of doing his presentation, he'll give us a tour, give us some snacks, all that good stuff. So
makes perfect sense to kind of add a little more fluff to what we're doing. And rather than sitting
around a table, change the scenery a little bit and go from here. But yeah, he asked if they could
show off his new showroom and give it to other warehouse. I'm like, that sounds great. Cool.
All right. Then hopefully, like I said, assuming I don't have any setbacks, I hope to see you there.
All right, buddy. All right, Paul. Let's talk to you soon. Thanks.